Natalie Bennett's got into trouble a
number of times now in interviews is
that because the green policies are
nonsense or she's not up to it well I
think it's a different reason I think
it's actually because we are pushed more
possibly than other parties really on
the numbers I think that a lot of people
think our policies are untested which
isn't true actually because they're
testing other countries I think it's we
do get a degree of scrutiny I think
that's more than the other political
tools I haven't seen tough interviews
yet on other party's manifestos so I
look forward to them well we haven't had
all the manifestos yet but well we
haven't we certainly had tough
interviews on on spending plans I I
hoped and I done them myself but I mean
just let's just take the big picture
would the greens overall tax the British
people more probably yes but you see I
think you well I don't know because I
haven't got our manifesto yeah we're a
Democratic Party in our manifesto have
to go through our conference procedure
and so we won't know until two or three
weeks exactly what the content yeah
basically you you think the state should
be bigger and it should be spending more
so you need to tax people more I said
Lee it should be big than it is at the
moment I think what the Tories have done
is actually destroyed our society in
many ways and I think they've made life
much harder for vulnerable people and I
think it's a common misperception that
people aren't prepared to pay their tax
I think I personally like paying tax
first of all because it means I earn
enough to pay it and sugary drink yeah I
are you offering now yeah wonderful yeah
of course jeribai duty-free uh why don't
go through very much I hate I do get
robbed would you I probably that's a
sort of tax avoidance isn't it well tax
avoidance perhaps but perfectly legal
unfortunately that the point is people
most people avoidance is perfectly most
people though I think understands their
taxes go towards paying for a better
society that if you want roads and you
want the NHS and you want police you
have to pay from somehow and so that's
where our taxis go all right I thought
the well so it goes for us personally I
would like to see fewer roads that's
absolutely true I think that we don't
put enough into public transport we
don't put enough into the railways I
mean that's
a Green Party manifesto probably in our
manifesto now really nationalization I
mean correct me if I'm wrong as I as I
understand the essential difference of
what the Greens are saying in this
election compared to all the other
parties is that you are opposed to
growth so that basically it will be a
fairer society a bit cleaner society but
it would be a poorer society well not
necessarily because some green measures
actually save you money and and won't
and working for example we would like to
see more houses insulated through the
state through through the government
we'd like to see people actually have
cheaper electricity because they're
using solar solar panels on their houses
sometimes going green can be cheaper for
you and it makes much more sense when we
talk about growth what we're saying is
you have to understand we have limited
resources and so if you grow in one area
you've got to shrink in another because
we cannot go on expanding and as far as
as the leadership is concerned is there
any thought of maybe putting up someone
else's as person that's that's not how
we run we're a democratic party Natalie
got elected I think she's due to come up
again for reelection in September I'm
sure she'll stand again and there might
be people who stand against Ted Laramie
for example the broadcast is still
proposing two debates in which the
Greens would take part do you think she
is the best represent of the Greens can
happen in she's our leader and therefore
she has to do the debates quite honestly
she has done thousands of interviews and
most of them are superb occasion she has
a bad one but I'd rather have somebody
like her who is baby it's all Caroline
Lucas could do it I mean you know
there's a lot of shortage I mean you
used to have eight leaders I seem to
remember we used to show the green all
very talented as well no I think they're
coming we've ever hidden here yes
being a Satori as well wasn't here well
he was great he was a great speaker one
state and he and a football player I
mean you can't hold everything sports
commentator
but um having something like Natalie who
believes in what she's saying she's
honest and straightforward it but she
she had an off day today well that's
better than having somebody slick and
smooth who doesn't believe word they're
saying and I think the other political
parties have people like that
and they don't wouldn't fit in a green
party I'm afraid okay lady Jones thank
you very much thank you